[Applause]
I grew up on a beef Farm in Missouri and
like everybody else that raises
livestock we raise a lot of our own feed
to stay in business and we raise corn
and soybeans and hay and we grind this
stuff up into a flower and we'd add
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
make pellets and you feed those calvs
for about six nine months and then you
ship them off to be butchered or maybe
to other feeders and you always save
back the very best ones for yourself and
you knock them in the head and eat them
it's a real simple cycle on the farm and
the thing that fascinated me as a
teenager was that we went to a great
deal of trouble for those calves and yet
as a family we ate out of the very same
Fields we'd keep back five rows of corn
for oursel we had a garden at the end of
the field where we grew our peas and
beans and squash and tomatoes and we
wanted to live to be a hundred with no
aches and pains and we didn't give
ourselves the very same vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals that we gave
the calves and I always used to ask my
dad I say hey Pops how come we go to all
that trouble for those calves and and
not for ourself and he'd say shut up boy
getting Farm Fresh Food fresh air lots
of free exercise don't ask complicated
questions and I was glad to get rid of
the farm exercise and go to a school at
the University of Missouri and there my
major was in animal husbandry and
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils and I began to learn technical
things about soil chemistry and how it
related to tons and bushels per acre and
a economics but I didn't get an answer
to my basic question until I became a
freshman Veterinary student at the
University of Missouri and there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds bottom line
is because we don't have insurance for
them we don't have Blue Cross Blue
Shield major medical hospitalization
Medicare Medicaid and if we were to use
a human health care type of system for
Animals it'd be sticker shock for you
your hamburger would cost you $275 a
pound boneless skinless chicken breast
would be 450 bucks a pound dozen eggs
would be $50 just to pay for the health
care so we learned that we could keep
the price of animal products such as
meat and dairy and poultry and eggs down
to where the average American amican
could afford them simply by
significantly reducing or totally
eliminating healthc care cost and we do
that in Animals by preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition well after
graduating vet school I went to Africa
for a couple years and got to work with
Marlon Perkins from the old Mutual of
Omaha Wild Kingdom days that was kind of
a kick got to play Frank Buck use a
tranquilizer gun tromp all over Central
and South Africa for a couple of years
and then Marlon sent me a telegram and
invited me back to the States uh he'd
gotten a $7.5 million Grant from the
National Institute to health and this
was more than 30 years ago and this was
to study pollution and ecology and the
environment and my job as the Wildlife
veterinarian on the project was to do
autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the big zoos around
the United States and I was supposed to
identify or find a species of animals
was Ultra sensitive to pollution and
we're going to use that animal much like
the old coal miners used to use canaries
you know how that goes they take the
canary down in the mine and if methane
gas or carbon monoxide were to leak into
the mine the canaries were more
sensitive than the men and uh would drop
off the Persian die and long before the
men were in danger of suffocating or
blowing up well to make a long story
short after some 12 plus years of
working on this project and done some
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals plus 3,000 human beings for a
comparison and what I learned was that
every animal and human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency disease and I got kind of
excited about nutrition again and I
wrote 75 scientific papers on the
subject uh wrote chapters for eight
multi-author textbooks actually
contributed a textbook myself a th000
Pages 2,000 illustrations and uh through
the news releases that were in the big
universities I worked with I was on 2020
was in 1700 newspapers around the world
through the UPI and AP newswire services
and with all this public exposure and
with all this scientific exposure I
couldn't get people who are in a
position of authority either in medical
research or in politics you get two
concerned earned or interested in
preventing and curing diseases in human
beings with nutrition just like we did
in animals well I got frustrated enough
I went back to school in Portland argon
became a physician and I practiced there
for 12 years as a general family
practitioner and Uh I seed up chainsaw
wounds delivered babies um used
everything that I'd learned in
Veterinary nutrition of my human
patients and it was no surprise to me
that it worked just as well in people as
it did in animal well to get started I
always like to talk about longevity and
the human being has the genetic
potential to live healthfully to be 120
I'm going to prove that to you in just a
minute unfortunately Americans do a
lousy job when it comes to longevity our
average lifespan in the United States is
75.5 about half we're genetically
capable of in 1990 when the World Health
Organization examined the top 32
industrialized nations on Earth the
United States came out 17th there's
actually 16 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do we ranked
19th in healthfulness that meant that
there were 18 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do before
they develop heart disease and cancer
and diabetes and arthritis and
osteoporosis we ranked 23rd when it came
to live births and first year
survivability of babies and we ranked
dead last 32 out of 32 when it came to
preventing birth defs now what all this
means is we have the highest price
Health Care system in the world but not
the best it also means that we have the
most envied Health Care system in the
world but not the best we have the most
technologically advanced Health Care
system in the world but not the best I
had a good friend by the name of
Christopher bird for many many years
over 20 years and Chris was a
bestselling author on books on AR gly
grown food he was an expert in this
subject and I was always trying to give
him vitamins and minerals and he refused
to take them and he' tell me Doc I bring
my own cooler I don't eat any uh Hotel
food I bring my own organically grown
food and so I don't need to take
vitamins and minerals while I was
changing planes again in Atlanta had an
hour to kill picked up the local
newspaper and guess whose obituary I
found in the newspaper Chris bird of
course again he was a best-selling
author of books The Secret Life of
plants the secrets of the soil and he
died at age 68 from a ruptured aneurysm
a type of stroke 7 and A2 years before
the average American dies and he led a
pristine life lived up in the mountains
had an organy grown Garden collected
herbs you know like Ule Gibbons and ate
wild Hickory nuts and all those kind of
things and because of his belief he died
of a copper deficiency and I'll show you
in a minute that copper deficiency
causes ruptured aneurysms and it's just
a tragic thing that that people have so
much to give and die at less than half
their genetic potential for lch onity a
lot of people say to me Doc I don't need
to take vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals because I use herbs now herbs
are not nutrition you have to understand
that herbs are not nutrition they are
great plant medicines uh they're safer
they're more economical and most cases
are more effective than prescription
medications that doctors will give you
but they're plant medicines if you have
diarrhea they can tighten you up if you
have constipation they can loosen you up
if you have hypertension or high blood
pressure they can bring it down if you
have a fever they bring it down but
don't expect to get enough calcium or
selenium or Boron or copper or vitamin A
from herbs well I've been doing
biomedical research and Clinical
Research in animals and human beings and
I can tell you no matter how you look at
Health and Longevity whether it be in
animals or human beings there's only
really two concepts you have to deal
with Concept number one I refer to is
avoid stepping on the landmines this is
where you don't want to throw away your
Healthy physical body wastefully you
don't want to smoke don't abuse alcohol
don't do drugs don't jog down the
highway at 2 o'clock in the morning
wearing an all black ninja suit you're
going to get hit by a truck mirror right
whenever a doctor says here's our
options never say Doc whatever you say
you're the you're the doctor when a
doctor says here's our options what you
want to do is say look I want copies of
all these records and tests I want
copies of the x-rays and go visit three
other doctors and three other hospitals
you want to talk to 12 of their living
patients that had gone through this
procedure talk to them see if you really
want to do this I mean you do this for
your driveway and your roof and your
fence and your yard and all that kind of
stuff why not for your own physical body
that's concept number one now that
you've avoided the landmines you're in a
good position to do all the positive
things that you need to do to go on to
live to be over 100 basically what you
want to do is take all the essential
nutrients 60 that's 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
three essential fatty acids and they're
called essential nutrients for two
reasons number one your body cannot
manufacture them you must consume these
every day either as food or supplements
number two if any one of these essential
nutrients is missing for a couple of
months couple of years you get on the
average 10 deficiency diseases you have
everything to gain nothing to lose by
supplementing properly well the medical
profession of course has this malignant
dumb belief that you can get everything
you need from your four food groups my
favorite article of all time in the was
April 6 1992 Time Magazine cover article
the real power of vitamins new research
shows it may help fight cancer heart
disease and the ravages of Aging six
positive Pages if you haven't read it
I'd urge you to go to a public library
School library dig it out and read it
there was only one negative sentence and
as you might guess it was offered by a
medical doctor who was actually uh
contacted by the writer of the article
said what do you think about vitamins
and minerals and and trace minerals as
supplements for human nutrition here's
what he said quote popping vitamins
doesn't do you any good sniffs Dr Victor
Herbert a professor of Medicine at New
York City's Mount siai medical school we
get all the vitamins we need in our
diets and taking supplements just gives
you expensive urine unquote now Missouri
translation of that is you're just
peeing away your money you might as well
W up your dollars throw them in a toilet
and flush them away you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups is what he's trying to say well
I'd rather pee out 50 cents or a dollar
a day worth of excess vitamins and
minerals that's cheap insurance think
about it how much money you spend for
coffee or soft drinks or newspapers and
that kind of stuff every day 50 cents to
a dollar a day to maintain and repair
your body and it's kind of fascinating
that most people don't do it just
remember when you pay that doctor out of
your own pocket or indirectly through
insurance or indirectly through taxes
and Medicare Medicaid not a single penny
of that goes to better understand manage
treat prevent or cure catastrophic
diseases in kids breast cancer in women
prostate cancer and men now a lot of
people ask me why did you call your
original tape Dead Doctors Don't Lie
well that's because I I believe for a
long time because I'd done medical
research for over 20 years in large
medical research institutes medical
schools the various Laboratories and I
always had a belief in the medical
system but I I was very disappointed
when I learned that doctors don't know
the most about Health and Longevity
doctors don't know the most about
disease they do know about procedures
you know how to fix your bones when you
break them and that sort of thing how to
do a CAT scan and so I began to look in
the medical journals and sure enough the
first article ever published on Health
and Longevity of American doctors was
published in jamama in June 15th 1895 a
little over 100 years ago they said at
that time doctors lived to be
54.6 I redid the study 97 years later
using the same obituary techniques that
they did in jamama This was um January
20th 1993 that particular issue of
jamama and it turned out the doctors
lived to be 57.6 I rounded up to 58 to
give them the benefit of the doubt and
doctors just went berserk when I said
that I mean this was the most outrageous
thing that they ever heard my principle
is my my premise is that doctors don't
live as long as the average couch potato
in America and I purposfully put that
figure out there at 58 to try and
challenge people well doctors
immediately looked at all the insurance
Actuarial charts they got 250,000 Dead
Doctors he said your group's too small
so they looked at 250,000 dead doctors
they say doctors don't live to be 58
they died 62 they still don't live to be
75.5 like the average couch potato we
actually reran this again using the
entire obituary history for 1996 and for
the entire 1996 of all the doctors dying
in 1996 with all the Medical Treatments
and drugs and and procedures and
everything and transplants doctors and
in that study lived to be 70 still 5 and
a half years short of the average couch
potato in America so they still have
never proven that Doctors live as long
as everybody else and that's why Dead
Doctors Don't Lie now if you do
everything right how old can you live to
be is it worth all the effort I believe
it is here's one Christian mortson from
San Rafel California in August of 1995
turned 113 August of 1996 he turned 114
he's still going strong certainly can
live to be 115 smokes a couple of cigars
a day like George Burns who also lived
to be over 100 certainly was I guess the
only exercise George Burns ever did was
put the cigars in his mouth this gal
here Dora rbe from South Africa in July
of 1995 turned 114 and when she was
asked by the media Dora what do you
attribute Your Health and Longevity to
she did not say that we owe it all to
our annual physical our our HMO she said
I ate Locust every day you know a little
grasshopper she's not a vegetarian she
eats little animals pumpkin seeds
tortoise meat Wilder herbs dried fruit
and starts each day with a cup of coffee
this gal here Margaret SKS from Radford
Virginia in 1994 was the oldest
documented living American when she died
at age of 115 fell over and fractured
her hip three weeks later she was dead
from complications of osteoporosis a
simple Calcium deficiency and we'll talk
more about this in a minute
unfortunately this is not unusual 75% of
all Americans over the age of 65 who
fracture a hip or major leg bone don't
live 90 days they die pneumonia
pulmonary embolism stroke and other
complications of that fracture Susie
Brunson according to her family in
December of 1994 was the oldest American
when she died at age of 123 and they
based her claim on her birth date
December 25th 1870 which was recorded in
the Family Bible and this fellow here
Francisco Barrison w at chapina October
1995 he was from a little town outside
of bogat Columbia turned 125 when he was
asked by the media Francisco what do you
attribute Your Health and Longevity to
he said well I drink a gallon of goats
milk every day also it's kind of
fascinating in his birthday announcement
this is not an obituary this is a
birthday anoun announcement said that
over 40 years ago his Physicians told
him he only had a couple of months to
live so he had his sons build him a
coffin and uh he's been waking up every
morning for more than 40 years sitting
by that coffin waiting to
die good night time comes he goes to bed
wakes up the next morning sits by the
coffin waits to die now he's still going
strong and all the doctors who told him
that more than 40 years ago are long
since dead now this fellow here Hamudi
El Abdullah from Syria died age 133 and
he was still fathering children after
the age of 100 he um remarried for the
fourth time when he was age 80 fathered
four boys five girls nine children after
the age of 80 with the same wife and we
add up the pregnancies and the
breastfeeding the time in between
pregnancies he was still fathering
children after the age of 100 now this
very next one is my very very favorite
this gal maumi Dusty from Iran according
to the Rocky Mountain news wire Services
out of Denver and the Iranian news
agency this was January of 1995 she died
at age of 161 now you have to give a
certain amount of credibility to this
obituary report that she died at age 161
because she was survived by six living
children ranging in age from 120 to 128
they hadn't even left home to go to
college
yet now her oldest son Golam said his
mother had never visited a doctor nor
taken any chemical medications during
her life did take a few herbs so if you
kind of think about it every one of
these people who Liv to be over a 100
12030 160 these people are not from
United States or Canada or Germany or
England kind of interesting isn't it
they're most of them are from third
world countries they're furthest away
from medical help and they live to be
old so that we're beginning to collect
information here the last one we want to
look at the National Geographic Society
a very respected group of uh people
scientists and and so forth and support
groups for science uh comes out with a
monthly magazine the National Geographic
magazine of course and they uh in
January of 1973 came out with a Nifty
special issue on longevity they they
looked at cultures whose people live 120
and they documented the oldest living
human being that they could find based
on their criteria this fellow by the
name of shirali misala from azerbijan a
little country just south of Russian
Georgia and Western Russia today they
documented him as being 167 years old
remember this is the National Geographic
Society not the national enquir 167
years of age and they had a half page
picture of him actually harvesting tea
leaves in a Tea Plantation still working
8 hours a day six days a week when he's
167 5 months later May of 1973 charal
molof turns 68 goes out and hes the
garden for reporters to show how
vigorous he is now for at least 50 maybe
70 years medical doctors in America have
been poo pooing the idea that you could
live well beyond 100 you know people who
lived 115 120 they were one in six
billion it wasn't something that
everybody could look forward to and
anybody who tried to teach people how to
live to be 110 120 140 were considered
charlatans and quacks and taking
advantage of uh older people I was glad
to see this come out this was a news
article on the USA Today newspaper in
October of 2000 and it was based on a
article in the journal science very
respectable journal and what they said
was forget 100 try living past
120 humans possess a maximum life
expectancy longer than 120 years which
is been the long theorized medical limit
in fact lifespans appear to be
increasing over time with no end in
sight now the key part of this is now
that there's no doubt about it everybody
agrees that human beings including
Americans have the genetic capacity to
live well beyond 120 doctors want to
take credit for it the things that have
actually increased our longevity from 45
average lifespan in 1895 to 75.5 today
which is an increase of about 30 and A2
years are sewers in good clean
water public health things we don't have
Calera and leptos perosis and
tuberculosis in our food supply and our
water supply anymore we have Meat
Inspection we have public water works
and things we have sewers these are the
things that have extended then there's
this salt thing now whether you believe
it or not this medical Dogma has really
caused a lot of problems in America how
many you ever heard that using the salt
shaker is bad you're going to get
hypertension right you're going to get
heart disease and stroke what's the
first thing a good farmer puts out for
his livestock a salt block or Salt Lick
isn't it there's nobody out in the
pasture telling a cow she's limited to
one lick a
day I refuse to believe that my human
patients are dumber than a cow say look
go ahead and pick up a salt shaker and
you're going to see that lightning won't
strike you you can go ahead and salt
your food to salt your body nothing bad
is going to happen and 98% of my
patients love it they bring me hundreds
of new patients every month who want to
use salt and not feel guilty about it
and 2% the bean counters they say now
wall we love you and respect you we have
this high price cardiologist that says
you're flying in the face of all the
weight and medical evidence you can't
tell people that um they can use a salt
shaker because you're going to kill them
with high blood pressure and heart
disease and stroke and I've been
Vindicated in this belief this was
actually a study that was published in
the New York Times May 22nd 1996 and
this study was abstracted from jamama
the Journal of the American Medical
Association the most prestigious medical
journal in the world according to
themselves now in this particular
journal A Dr Alexander Gordon Logan who
is an epidemiologist and cardiologist on
the teaching staff of the medical school
at the University of Toronto up in
Canada and he took 56 existing studies
on hypertension or high blood pressure
and restriction of salt combin the data
from these 56 studies which included 355
people he threw away all the conclusions
and re-evaluated the larger group and
what he found out was this if you have
normal blood pressure and you restrict
salt it will not prevent you from
getting heart disease or high blood
pressure if you have hypertension or
high blood pressure in your restrict
salt 97% of those with high blood
pressure or hypertension who restrict
salt will not get any measurable benefit
97% will not get any measurable benefit
zero two to 5% get measurable benefit
but it's not significant they're only
able to reduce their blood pressure by
3.7 mm of mercury so here's what Dr
Alexander Gordon Logan said in jamama
May 22nd 1996 he said you might as well
go ahead and salt your food to taste
it's a meaningless exercise don't get
paranoid about salt it has nothing to do
with blood pressure problems there has
never been one single iota of proof that
restricting salt has any benefit it's
just one of those medical myths he
called it but I'm going to call it a
medical cocka now if it's not salt what
causes high blood pressure well it's not
salt first of all because salt is an
essential nutrient has a combination of
sodium and chloride both of which you
need and according to the American Heart
Association the minimum daily
requirement for 150 pound person for
salt each day is a heaping teaspoon 6
to9 grams of salt a day now the Japanese
who live longer than we do the Japanese
who live 4.1 years longer than we do and
have half the cancer rate they eat 12
grams of salt a day they eat three times
the salt we do and they live four years
longer have half the cardiov vaster
disease rate
and half the cancer rate we do and yet
they eat three times as much salt as we
do so you're beginning to put the puzzle
together the doctors really don't know
what they're talking about that's why
Dead Doctors Don't Lie well if it's not
the salt and if it's not genetic what is
it well it's actually just a simple
mineral deficiency raise your hand you
ever heard that cholesterol is bad and
you got to get it low in your blood you
got to have low cholesterol diet
otherwise you're going to get heart
disease right doctors would like to
blame all cardiovascular disease on
cholesterol we've known for 75 years in
the animal industry that cholesterol is
not a boogeyman there's not a single
disease that's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol or triglycerides you can
find me one I'll give you a million
dollars in small bills in any offshore
account you want there's not a single
disease that's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol or triglycerides elevated
blood cholesterol and triglycerides are
really just a warning signal much like a
fever fevers don't cause infections but
when you have an infection with a
bacteria a virus a fungus maybe a
parasite you can get a fever you can
have a broken leg and get a fever you
can have cancer get a fever you can have
liver disease and get a fever babies get
a fever when they teeth and so you have
to kind of sort it out when somebody
comes into a doctor's office with a
fever you have to say well okay here's
my whole list called a differential
diagnosis all the things that cause
fever if they're 80 years old you can
quickly rule out teething
right but the rest of you may have to do
some lab tests for any rate the same
thing is true for elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides when you
have elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides it might mean that you
have hypothyroidism or low functioning
thyroid gland you could have diabetes
you could have deficiencies of nasin
chromium vadium the essential fatty
acids you can have liver disease all
kinds of reasons why you might have
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides but they in themselves
don't cause any problems now the eskimos
above the Arctic Circle have a
traditional diet there 98% red meat and
blubber uh they whale meat whale blubber
walrus meat walrus blubber seal meat
seal blubber bare meat bare fat there's
not a single esimo above the Arctic
Circle that has a Mr juice man juicer
eats our ganly grown
broccoli their average cholesterol
ranges from 250 to 350 and yet they're
legendary for not getting cardiovascular
disease until they come down to the
lower 48 and eat like us then when they
get the cardiovascular disease they go
back home to die up above the Arctic
Circle they start eating whale blubber
again it goes away well learning all
that I felt very confident in telling my
patients look we're going to do
something different my goal as a
physician is to have my patients die at
an average age of 100 I don't want my
patients down to 75.5 I want to give
them another 25 years I want the average
lifespan for my patients to be 100
and we're going to do something
different if you want to do everything
that all the other doctors and patients
are doing I want you to go to them
because I don't want you to lower my
average right we're going to do
something different it's just real my
favorite disease is arthritis I love
arthritis the reason why I love
arthritis is it's easy to fix and when
you can fix something as horrible and as
debilitating as painful and as expensive
and as miserable as arthritis you get
kind of excited about this concept of
preventing and curing diseases with
nutrition and so I tell people about
this arthritis thing all the time so
let's have a quick look at AR Artis uh
number one 75 to 80% of all Americans
over the age of 50 get arthritis to one
degree or of one type or another and
according to the CDC the Center for
Disease Control 35 to 50 million baby
boomers are going to get arthritis in
the next 7 to 10 years and there's not a
single medical treatment designed to
prevent or fix it aspirin certainly
doesn't fix arthritis cause gastric
bleeding and death tanol doesn't fix
arthritis causes 50,000 cases of kidney
failure each year 5,000 which are so
severe you need a kidney transplant then
there's ibuprofen ad vill and a leave
these things don't fix arthritis and
they cause liver disease in 2 to 5% of
the users including liver ceros even if
you don't drink and then there's
methotraxate and gold shots these things
don't fix arthritis they subdue your
bone marrow so you can't make normal
platelets and white blood cells and then
you have the granddaddies of all the
medical treatments for arthritis prazone
and cortisone they don't fix arthritis
they subdue your immune system which
leaves you open to diseases far far more
horrible than arthritis and prazone and
cortisone accelerate the loss of
minerals from your bone some something
you don't want when you have
osteoporosis and arthritis now when
these prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and inflammation
the only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and I I never
like to send my patients in for the
joint replacement surgery because they
never work out well in fact many times
you're worse off after the surgery than
you were before the surgery the
advantage my patients have always had is
that I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and so I always used to tell
my patients look we have all these
nutritional formulas designed to prevent
and cure diseases in animals including
arthritis and so I tried adapting
nutritional arthritis formulas designed
to prevent and cure arthritis and
pigeons and turkeys dogs cats sheeps
pigs horses cows lions tigers and bears
to human use it was no surprise to me it
works just as well in humans as it does
in animals because it was designed to
prevent and cure arthritis and pigs and
I've literally seen tens of thousands of
people who've had a regrowth of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone Foundation bone matrix
doesn't matter if they're 20 30 40 50 60
70 80 90 I've seen people 97 years old
regrow caragen bone even if they had
bone to- bone arthritis if there's blood
supply to that joint in that bone they
will regrow uh bone and carage well of
course Harvard Medical School goes
berserk when you say stuff like that
wall like you can't say those things the
only thing left for people when they get
bone to- bone arthritis is joint
replacement surgery and I I'd agree with
him if the only raw materials you're
using is Tylenol and aspirin and Penzone
and cortisone we've learned over 50
years that you can't regrow carage and
bone using those things one of the basic
things of course the Harvard Medical
School jumped on to and they said this
is so ridiculous that this couldn't work
and so they took 29 patients arthritis
patients who had failed to respond in
any way to heroic medical treatment for
arthritis over 15 to 20 years they took
them off all their medication wasn't
working for them anyway lined them up
for joint replacement surgery and they
said look for 90 days before we do the
surgery they gave him a heaping
tablespoon full of ground up chicken
carage in their orange juice every
morning for 90 days they were sort of
chuckling in their beer saying nothing's
going to happen well here's what
happened in 10 days these people these
29 people had complete relief of pain
inflammation something they hadn't had
in 15 to 20 years in 30 days they could
Now open up a new pickle jar that never
been opened without pain to the fingers
wrist elbows and shoulders in 90 days 28
of the 29 were clinically cured now this
is from Harvard Medical School in the
Boston VA that meant that they had
complete Return of the range of motion
all the pain inflammation was gone in
their fingers and toes and hips and
knees and their neck and certainly many
of them still had knots on their fingers
because it was only 90 days and you'd
think they'd call me up these professors
you know of medicine from Harvard
Medical School and from the Boston VA
and say look wallet we have to apologize
to you we've been bad mouthing you for
20 years and why don't you come up to
Boston let's talk about the whole thing
here's what they said quote after three
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote chicken cartilage had
become a drug in 90
days now why would that happen well
because you can't patent chicken carage
and uh they convinced that the US patent
office that they were using a drug to do
this study and they actually got a use
patent on chicken carage and you two for
3500 bucks a month can get Harvard
Medical school's chicken carage in a
capsule for arthritis of course
cartilage has condr and sulfate in it
glucosamine sulfate collagen these are
all the basic raw materials to rebuild
carage and Bone raise your hand if you
know what the red warning light is for
on the dashboard of a car truck back
before we had dials showing temperatures
and things they used to use the red
warning light right it was called The
Idiot light and when that red warning
light came on it meant that your engine
was heating up you didn't have enough
coolant or oil or maybe you broke a fan
belt or split a radiat hose and a
reasonable person would would pull the
vehicle car or truck over the side of
the road and deal with the problem so
you didn't burn the engine up even even
a Mercedes would burn up if you didn't
have enough coolant and oil and a fan
belt and a radiator hose then of course
the village idiot that's why they call
it the Village Idiot light or the idiot
light they'd be driving along they'd see
that red warning light come on they say
I don't have time to deal with this so
they whip out their plowers they cut the
wire of the red warning light they keep
on driving even a Mercedes will burn up
if it doesn't have oil cooling a fan
belt and a radiator hose right and so
you really have to be The Village Idiot
to do that nobody in the right mind
would do that to their vehicle how many
of you know what pain is far raise your
hand if you know what pain is far that's
pretty good most of you know that pain
is the red warning light for your body
when you get pain in your foot your
ankle your leg your knee your hip your
back your shoulders elbows wrist and
fingers your body saying don't use those
joints don't use those bones don't use
those muscles until you fix them it's
absolutely criminal absolutely criminal
for a doctor to write you a prescription
for a pain reliever an anti-inflammatory
or muscle relaxing or any of those
combinations without rebuilding the
bones and the joints and the cartilage
at the same time if they just give you a
pain reliever just give you an
anti-inflammatory andar muscle relaxing
without rebuilding the joints and the
bones at the same time all they're doing
is cutting the wire of the red warning
light you're going to wear those bones
and joints and carage out faster and
faster and faster it's actually a
negative to be taking painkillers and
anti-inflammatories without rebuilding
the joints and the bones at the same
time the reason why I say no carbonated
drinks and I've been doing that since
1964 is because carbonated drinks
actually will neutralize your stomach
acid
and you cannot efficiently absorb
minerals digest protein or absorb
vitamin B12 without stomach acid you
have to have stomach acid like battery
acid doctors have the criminal belief
that you don't need stomach acid and
they give you all these drugs to get rid
of your stomach acid ant acids and they
give you drugs that stop producing
stomach acid right they don't want you
to have stomach acid absolutely criminal
you can't digest food and absorb food
without stomach acid I know most of you
knew that carbonat drinks neutralized
stomach acid if you remember back 25 50
75 years ago when somebody would ask
their doctor to say look I just ate a i
overate i overate a Thanksgiving dinner
and I have heartburn and indigestion
what do I do that was before they had
Zantac they say well take some seven up
drink some ginger ale drink some club
soda take take some uh sparkling water
because the carbonation will neutralize
your stomach acid and give you some
relief and it would now if you do that
three times a year drink a carbonated
drink three times a year for
Thanksgiving and Christmas and Easter
because you overeat during those
holidays that's okay you're going to
survive but when you're drinking 2 3 4 5
6 8 10 carbonated drinks a day you're
not going to survive because over the
long haul you will not be able to absorb
the nutrients you're going to get some
horrible combination of terrible
diseases this came out June of 200000
and this is a Harvard study on 460
junior high school girls in nth and 10th
grade and what they found out was that
those Junior High School girls who drank
one non-cola carbonator drink every day
they increased their risk of fractures
and osteoprosis is a teenager by 300%
they found out that if they drank one
carbonated Cola drink a cola carbonated
drink every day they increase the risk
of fractures and osteoporosis as a
teenager by
500% now do you think that this is more
dangerous for teenagers or adults it's
much more dangerous for anals because
you only have 25% bone matrix and you're
very very slow to recover where
teenagers have 40% bone matrix and they
can recover in a week we learned in 1957
from a turkey study uh where they took
250,000 turkeys and they put them on a
complete turkey pellet trying to get
them to finish for Market within a few
days or a week or so of each other and
in the first 13 weeks fully half of them
125,000 of them died farmers were out
there every morning they picked them up
every morning by the bushel basket full
took them to the state Diagnostic lab to
see what they died from when they opened
them up every one of them had died of a
ruptured a Artic aneurysm and one of the
clever pathologist says that's got to be
due to a copper deficiency because
copper is required to manufacture the
elastic fibers of arteries and skin and
other tissues and the mechanism of an
aneurysm is identical to the mechanism
of a balloon on a weakened wall of a
tire you know when you hit a Chuck hole
with your tire and you break the cords
the internal pressure blows a balloon
you overload that tire with weight or
heat it up on a highway it blows out
same way with an aneurysm when you have
a copper deficiency you get a break down
of the elastic fibers uh in that artery
the internal pressure even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon in that
artery and a balloon in an artery is
called an aneurism and of course if it's
in a strategic place like the brain the
crowded artery the coronary arteries the
large arteries the aart pul artery renal
arteries they blow out you die suddenly
uh just like you've been shot well they
got excited about this they double the
amount of copper in these um pellets the
next year they tried to raise 500,000
turkeys and they did not lose a single
one from a ruptured aneurysm they went
from a 50% loss to a 0% loss just by
adding a little bit of copper to those
pellets so they said well maybe the same
thing is true for humans and in 19 uh 58
they started looking at copper
deficiency in various species of animals
and humans and here's what they found
out the very first symptom of copper
defic efficiency is white gray and
silver hair copper is required as a
co-factor to manufacture hair pigment
doesn't matter if it's blonde red brown
or black hair and I see a lot of copper
deficiency in this room I can almost
tell you which people men and women who
have colored their hair get pretty good
at that being a physician and you don't
want to be like a medical doctor and
just treat the symptoms if you're just
coloring your hair you're treating the
symptoms you need to do the basic thing
of take some colloidal copper and you
don't uh what's going to happen is uh
you get a breakdown of the elastic
fibers in your skin and you start
getting crows feet around the corners of
your eyes and your mouth parts of your
Anatomy begin to Sag and you know you're
in trouble when your doctor tells you
look I've got a golf buddy down the hall
who's a plastic surgeon for $10,000 will
make you look 20 years younger but you
don't need a face lift a booby lift a
tummy tuck or a dairy a lift all you
need is some copper and everything will
come back up just like you have a
hydraulic jack under it it'll just come
right back up those elastic fibers
tighten right up people say Francine did
you get a facelift you look great you
look like you're 20 years younger now if
you don't take some action at that point
the next thing that happens is you get
to break down the elastic fibers and the
Lar large veins of your legs and you get
varicose veins you don't take action at
that point you get a break down of the
elastic fibers and large veins of your
exhaust pipe and you get hemorrhoids so
if you have hemorrhoids varicose veins
things that sag wrinkles white gray or
silver here the odds are you have
aneurysms developing in you somewhere
and you don't want to of course die
suddenly of a ruptured aneurysm when
your body's been warning you for 10 20
30 years just remember people don't die
suddenly of an aneurysm it may be you
drop and die think about old Albert
Einstein he died of a ruptured air
aneurism at 68 years of age what color
was his hair he was famous for wild
white hair wasn't he now you'd like to
think that people who win the Nobel
Prize in medicine would at least live to
be 75.5 but they live to be 58 just like
other doctors and of course that's
because they are trained and they
believe and they practice you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups doesn't matter if they win the
Nobel Prize or not this guy here Dr
George Kohler was the youngest person
ever to win the Nobel Prize in medicine
in history 37 years old wins a Nobel
Prize in medicine and he won the Nobel
priz medicine for studying monoclonal
antibodies which are antibodies trained
to attack cancer cells and if they ever
get this really working it'll be great
because they won't have to use
chemotherapy anymore which kills more
people than it saves 11 years after
winning the Nobel Prize in Medicine Dr
George ker now 48 drops dead of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack because he
believed you can get everything you need
from your four food groups didn't take
any selenium died of a cardiomyopathy
heart now I have to tell you why
athletes are early warning system couch
potatoes by definition are people who go
to extraordinary efforts not to sweat
right they make every human effort not
to sweat they're changing the TV
channels honey bring in the popcorn I'm
changing the channels Sun bring me the
TV Guide I'm changing the channels by
contrast athletes have the attitude no
pain no gain and they're out there
sweating and working away power training
strength training running and they sweat
athletes no matter age they sweat more
than five years and couch potatoes do in
70 years and when you sweat you don't
just sweat out potassium and Gatorade
you sweat out all 60 essential minerals
if you sweat out all of your selenium
and don't replace it by supplementation
you're at higher risk of getting a
cardiopathy heart attack you sweat out
all of your copper and don't replace it
by supplementation you're at high risk
of developing an aneurysm and dying
suddenly of a ruptured aneurysm you
sweat out all of your chromium and
vadium and don't replace by
supplementation you're higher risk of
getting diabetes and if you sweat out
all of your calcium and magnesium and
Boron and zinc and sulfur and other
minerals are required for cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue bone
you're going to get a joint and Bone
injury what is the biggest single cause
of athletes career being ended early
joint and Bone problems right and that's
because they sweat out all the basic
minerals that they need to maintain
those parts of their body and they don't
supplement with them because doctors
tell them that they can get everything
they need by eating their four food
groups what are the early warning
systems for mineral deficiencies we
already told you about white gray or
silver hair for copper deficiency liver
spots are age spots in the back of your
hand side of your face or neck these
things are caused by a selenium
deficiency and you know again about
selenium deficiency then of course uh
you have toe cramps leg cramps you can
have hypertension these things are all
caused by a deficiency of calcium and if
you're an athlete at age 25 or 15 and
you get a leg cramp as a Calcium
deficiency your body's telling you if
you don't stop drinking those Pepsis and
started supplementing with some calcium
by the time you're 40 50 60 years old
you're going to have arthritis and
osteoporosis but most people say wow I
got to get this high price trainer I
need somebody who can give me massage
therapy because I have a cramp and they
don't go and take their supplements 85%
of the total mineral in your body is a
calcium there's 147 different diseases
you can get from a Calcium deficiency
we're just going to quickly go over the
top 10 when it comes to number of people
affected and the amount of money
involved let's look at osteoprosis the
number 10 killer of adults United States
remember 75% of the those overage 65 who
fracture a hip or major leg bone don't
live 90 days also it's the most horrible
disease when it comes to human misery
and dollars expended osteoporosis think
of the special Vans and the lift gates
and the ramps and the elevator the
special Plumbing in homes and and public
buildings special parking places
Wheelchairs and Walkers and Canes think
of the beds and the chairs that little
electric motors to lift you up when you
can't stand up by yourself physical
therapists joint replacement surgeries
Pharmaceuticals doctor visits we're
talking billions and billions of dollars
for nothing more than a Calcium
deficiency disease now as horrible as a
disease as osteoporosis is in human
beings we don't have osteoporosis and
animals because we don't have Blue Cross
Blue Shield major medical
hospitalization Medicare and Medicaid to
pay for non sensical surgical treatments
for mineral deficiency we've learned
that by putting animals who are weaned
off their mother's milk on calcium as
soon as they're weaned they won't get
arthritis and osteoprosis it's amazing
how that works receding gums dentist and
dental hyal tit to floss and brush after
every meal if you believe that works I
have some ocean front property in
Montana to sell you if you have receding
gums periodontitis gingivitis pyara
loose teeth Bridges and plates you
actually have osteoporosis of the facial
bones and the jaw bones we don't get
receding gums in animals even though
they don't floss or brush that's because
we've taken care of the osteoporosis
problem in animals arthritis 85% of all
arthritis is called wear and tear
arthritis osteoarthritis degenerative
arthritis anking spinalis these things
are nothing more than osteoporosis of
the joint ends of the bones hypertension
high blood pressure as you've learned
has nothing to do with salt or salt
restriction 85% of hypertension not
related to kidney disease which is most
of them not related to kidney disease is
in fact a Calcium deficiency insomnia is
not a deficiency of sleeping pills helon
or barbituates it's a deficiency of
calcium kidney stones bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits again the
medical profession has a malignant dumb
belief that these things are due to too
much calcium in your diet how to give up
calcium when in fact you only get kidney
stones bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits when you have raging
osteoporosis you actually need more
calcium more magnesium not less cramps
and Twitches raise your hand how many
you ever had a toe cramp foot cramp leg
cramp in your life sure that's the first
symptom of a Calcium deficiency that
most people recognize so if you've ever
had that sometime in your life you've
had a Calcium deficiency then you have
PMS the University of California San
Diego came out and said that 85% of the
emotional and physical stuff of PMs can
be relieved eliminated and cured they
use the Cure word by taking three times
the RDA of calcium low back pain has
nothing to do with disc problems I know
you've heard of people maybe even
yourself have had a diss surgery for
back pain and after the surgery you
still had the pain maybe even worse
because back pain is not caused by disc
problems if you have a disc problem you
can have numbness and tingling maybe
even paralysis if it's very severe but
disc problems do not cause we learned in
1957 in animals that we could prevent
and cure adult onset diabetes with two
trace minerals chromium and vadium 1985
the medical school at the University of
Vancouver British Columbia up in Canada
came out and said the trace mineral
vadium alone could replace insulin and
addal onset diabetics Science Diet dog
food has 4y mineral mineral in it always
has chromium vadium lithium and selenium
Ral Pina a laboratory rat pellets has 28
minerals always contains chromium vadium
lithium and selenium I'll give anybody
in this room a crisp new $100 bill if
you can find me a human infant formula
off the shelf of a grocery store that
has more than 12 minerals in it none of
them contain chromium vadium or lithium
only one proo well two actually proy and
infam I believe has 12 because they put
in the um selenium the rest of them
don't they have 11 10 nine or eight
minerals our dogs get 40 minerals our
rats get 28 and our kids get 12 or less
you don't have to be a research
scientist to realize why our kids are
now getting all these horrible diseases
that used to occur in people in their
60s 70s and 80s all these diseases that
that um doctors are wondering how is
this genetic these kids shouldn't have
this till they're 60 well that's because
they couldn't get it out of their little
can of stuff if it's not in the can they
don't get it again we need nutrients 16
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids three essential fatty acids IDs
and fortunately over the thousands of
years that human beings have been around
we haven't had to think much about this
because our food plants our grains
vegetables fruits and nuts take carbon
dioxide out of the air and manufacture
long carbon chains many of which are
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids and
this is where this medical cocka came
from that you can get everything you
need from your four food groups because
they say well plants grains fruits
vegetables and us can manufacture
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids but
we've tried this experiment for 200
years Americans have eaten better than
anybody else in the world we've had the
best quality food in the world over
anybody else and yet we only live to be
75.5 we don't set any health or
longevity records so if you want to live
to be over 100 can't get it from eating
your four food groups you can live to be
75.5 you may live 10 years older 10
years younger but on the average 75.5 so
if you want to live to be over 100 you
do have to supplement with vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids there's
three types of minerals you have to
concern yourself with first of all
there's metallic minerals these are
things like oyster shell eggshell lime
Stone Coral Calcium seabed minerals
Clays of various types Tums is a popular
one with doctors lactates gluconates
citrates oxides sulfates carbonates
these are nothing but ground of rocks
we're not designed to eat ground of
rocks nobody can show you where humans
or animals are designed to eat ground of
rocks we are designed to get our
minerals by eating plants grains
vegetables fruits and nuts and as a
result plant derived minerals are
absorbable more absorbable than chelated
more absorbable than the elal or
metallic minerals plant derived minerals
are liquid they're very small particle
size they're 7,000 times smaller than
red blood cell this is the way they're
stored in your cells and are moved
around in plant vascular systems and
human vascular systems and the um liquid
Plant deriv Farm they're negatively
charged I don't know all of the physics
and chemistry is one of the basic
features of a colloidal mineral that's
negatively charged these three factors
together give you absorbability now the
way it's supposed to be is our food
plants our grains vegetables fruits and
nuts take the elemental or metallic
minerals out of the soil convert them to
minerals for their own use for their own
metabolism and biochemistry and then
animals and people eat these plants that
are enriched with minerals that's how
we're designed to get our minerals
unfortunately we have several problems
here for hundred years we've used a
simple fertilizer known as NPK we put in
three nutrients into the soil when we
need 60 minerals we put those three
nutrients in the soil for maximum yields
per ton and bushel per acre uh then of
course we have to understand that plants
cannot manufacture minerals if they're
not in the soil they're not in the
plants plants only have minerals in them
if they're in the soil plants cannot
manufacture minerals over 90 years at
least we've been deficient in our soils
in America and as a result our food is
deficient and as a result the crops the
grains fruits vegetables and nuts that
are grown they are minerally deficient
and as a result the animals and people
who eat these minerally deficient crops
get mineral deficiency diseases and the
only way to prevent and cure them is
with mineral
[Applause]
supplements
yes I'm a construction worker and um I
hurt my back he said that my cartilage
damage is permanent is there anything
that can be done first of all how old
are you I'm 28 years old and what do you
normally take for fluid replacement we
working out in construction what do you
drink during the day uh water Gatorade
you don't drink any soft drinks uh yes I
do okay because normally construction
workers drink a couple of liters of
Pepsi a day right yeah I can probably
put down a liter per
easy and did you take any vitamins or
minerals that way were working in
construction um just recently started
when you were in construction prior to
the back problems yeah a lot of
construction workers will tell me Well
doc if it ain't in the Pepsi I don't get
it right and so uh you're a perfect
candidate for the pig arthritis formula
plus the EFA you need all 90 essential
nutrients and give up the bad things
give up the soft drinks and the ice tea
and the lemonades and and um give up the
fried foods and the margarin and uh I
can just tell you with your age uh you
can honestly expect to see some uh
really recognizable results in a very
very short time 60 to 90 days and it
doesn't matter what the doctor said if
you do the right things get rid of the
bad stuff take all 90 essential
nutrients uh making sure you get that
collagen and the glucosamine sulfate and
the condr and sulfate uh you will repair
your vertebrae you will repair the
cartilage and you will repair the disc
Dr Wall it just seems like every week I
pick up a newspaper and I see about our
young athletes having problems with
their bodies falling apart what can we
give our athletes and our children so
that they can be healthy and have long
lives that we want as well that's a
great question because most people
believe that exercise is good for you
and it was always a great question you
know is exercise good for you is it
necessary for Health and Longevity and
when you inspect this question uh you
have to look at professional athletes
who uh spend most of their teenage years
and going through University and the
semi-pros and the pros uh training and
practicing and doing their events and if
exercise was the factor in living a long
healthful life athletes should live
longer than couch potatoes but when you
look at this critically couch potatoes
in America live to be 75.5 and the
average athlete depending on the sport
and their level of competence live to be
62 to 68 far short of what a cou potato
lives to be and of course athletes
suffer from a great many joint diseases
and Bone injuries and tendons and
ligaments back necks shoulders ankles
knees and hips and have to suffer
through an enormous amount of surgeries
to deal with this and athletes develop
some 800 different diseases and what is
it why is it that athletes don't fa as
well as the couch potato well it's
simply because athletes sweat more in 5
years than couch potatoes do in 75 years
and when you sweat you're not just
sweating out Gatorade you're sweating
out all 60 essential minerals and
they're called essential minerals
because if they're missing for any
length of time you get some horrible
degenerative disease many of which which
are are life-threatening so you don't
have to be a rocket scientist to figure
out who's more likely to be debilitated
or even die of these these
lifethreatening diseases an athlete who
sweats out quarts of sweat during an
event or training or practice or a couch
potato who's laying on a couch in an air
conditioned Den switching the channels
yelling honey bring in the popcorn I'm
changing the channels and this is very
serious because the Center for Disease
Control says that as many as 100,000
young athletes under the age of 30 a
100,000 each year dies suddenly during
an event or training or exercise or
immediately after an event from
cardiopathy heart disease and ruptured
aneurysm and we know that cardiopathy
heart disease is due to a selenium
deficiency and ruptured aneurysms is due
to a copper deficiency so it can begin
to put two and two together why does a
10-year-old die of a ruptured aneurysm
well he sweat out all of his copper and
you can't get copper from curly french
fries and Pepsis it just doesn't work Dr
Wall what about arthritis well arthritis
is my favorite disease because it's easy
to fix uh it's one of the great myths
that the medical profession perpetuates
is that you can't build bone mass after
the age of 50 60 70 years of age you can
only slow down the loss and the reason
why they say that is because they try to
rebuild bone mass using plain calcium
whether it's Tums or calcium citrate or
carbonate or gluconate or or lactate and
your body will not retain much or any of
the calcium you supplement within your
bones without first building new bone
matrix you have to have new bone matrix
this is this this rubbery collagen
material that looks like tendon or skin
and it makes up 25 to 40% of our bone
weight 40% when you're a child and 25%
when you're an adult and so it's
absolutely essential if you want to deal
with the wear and tear arthritis
osteoarthritis degenerative arthritis
anking spondilitis effectively you have
to take all 90 essential nutrients and
the best way to do that is with Dr
Wall's Pig arthritis for formula
remember I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and we learned a long time ago
maybe 100 years ago in veterinary
medicine that we could actually prevent
and reverse maybe even use the Cure word
in animals arthritis simply by giving
the animal the raw material to develop
properly and to maintain and repair the
joints and so using this information
that we developed in animals if you use
the same concept for human beings I have
literally seen tens of thousands of
people over the years who had bone to-
bone arthritis they had osteoarthritis
they have degenerative arthritis anking
spondilitis which are basically a joint
form of osteoporosis it's osteoporosis
The Joint ends the bones and they've
tried all kinds of medication and of
course if you take medication if you
take a painkiller if you take an
anti-inflammatory for arthritis
essentially all you're doing is cutting
the wire the red warning light pain in a
joint says don't use me until you fix me
and by taking a painkiller by taking a
anti-inflammatory which will reduce pain
you're allowing that joint to be used
even though it would have been painful
without the drug and so you're wearing
that joint out faster and faster and
faster and to me it's criminally
negligent for someone to be prescribed a
painkiller or an anti-inflammatory for
joint disease without repairing The
Joint at the same time and this is where
the pig arthritis formula really shines
and works just like a charm in human
beings so does the same apply for bone
spurs absolutely bone spurs are a
manifestation of osteoporosis a person
will get bone spurs and calcium deposits
when you have osteoporosis just the
opposite of what a doctor will tell you
and you need more calcium more magnesium
you need the bone matrix you need the
collagen the glucosamine sulfate the
condr and sulfate and those bone spurs
and the calcium deposits will actually
re architecture back down to a normal
bone takes a little while takes four to
6 months to pull that off but you can do
it on a regular basis absolutely cancer
seems to be striking everywhere in our
population these days what do we have
that we can help people that are facing
the challenge of cancer that's a great
question uh back at the turn of the
century 1895 1900 one out of 10
Americans developed cancer right now
it's three out of five and by the year
2050 it's projected two out of three
people are going to develop cancer in
America the onset of cancer appears to
be directly related to the amount of of
carcinogens these our toxic waste either
from agriculture or from the Industrial
Waste that we find in our air and our
food and our water and in the dust
around us and the lack of the ability to
toen against these these carcinogens and
the most common defense mechanism that
we have the one that we have access to
in a very economical way are the
antioxidants like selenium like the
grape seed extract like the green tea
you're looking at Vitamin E vitamin C
beta carotene and avoiding fried foods
and margins and and things that we have
control of eating as much or gantly
grown food as possible and according to
the medical school at the University of
Arizona and this came out in jamama the
Journal of the American Medical
Association December 25th 1996 I mean
we're talking about a great Christmas
gift to the American
people they did a wonderful study 10
years it was a double blind study 1300
people they gave the study group 250
micrograms which is one qu of 1
milligram and talking an itsy bitsy
amount of selenium they just use
selenium alone didn't change anything
else and by giving these people 250
micrograms one qu of a milligram of the
trace mineral selenium they were able to
reduce the risk of esophageal cancer by
71% prostate cancer by 69% greater than
2/3 colon and rectal cancer by 64%
almost 2/3 lung cancer was reduced by
48% whether you smoked or not and in a
parallel study from the University of
California San Diego 250 micrograms one
qu of 1 milligram of selenium the Trac
of selenium reduce the risk of breast
cancer by 50 to 80% and the same study
showed that if you already have cancer
if you take 250 micrograms of selenium
every day uh you will in fact double the
Natural History life expectancy of a
particular type of cancer for instance
lung cancer the Natural History is about
a year brain cancer is less than a year
uh uterine ovarian colon uh breast
cancer is two to 5 years prostate cancer
is 5 to 8 years well just by taking 250
micrograms of the trace Minal selenium
every day one quarter of 1 milligram
according to the University of of
Arizona's Medical School uh you can
double that life expectancy just by
doing that one thing and so if you take
the other antioxidants and give up
margins and fried foods and sugar and
caffeine and avoid as many of the
Agricultural waste and the toxic waste
from the industry that you can you will
be able to avoid an enormous amount of
cancer and if you already have cancer
doing other things such as taking the um
antioxidants and getting on macrobiotic
diets and and so forth you can add many
healthful years to your life you can
certainly have a better quality of life
and many people uh will extend their
lives in a in a great way 10 20 30 40
years and obviously there's no way you
can look in somebody's eyes and say
you're the one that's going to live 50
years and so people just have to do all
the right things and they're going to
get the best that can be gotten from
nutrition and the the supplement Dr W
like I've been a diabetic for about 30
years what can what kind of mineral
should I take to help me okay well first
of all are you an adult onset type 2
diabetic or a juvenile onset type 1
diabetic juvenile onset type 1 you are
in insulin dependent because the
definition of a juvenile onset type 1
diabetic is that you do not make any
insulin and so you will never be able to
wean off of insulin you will always have
to take some insulin but there are two
trace minerals chromium and vadium that
will make the insulin that you
supplement yourself with very efficient
and most people who are juvenile onset
type 1 diabetics are able to reduce the
amount of insulin they require to
stabilize their blood sugar uh by
supplementing with the chromium and
vadium normally a person learns how to
adjust their insulin by taking their
blood sugar once or twice or three times
a day and so you're taught how to adjust
your insulin intake and just by
following what you've been taught as you
supplement with his plant derived
colloidal and the chelated chromium and
vadium you will be able to get down to a
new dosage of your insulin and the value
of taking the whole pig arthritis
formula is that there's nothing worse
than paying attention to your blood
sugar levels your insulin intake and
then dying of a ruptured aneurysm
because you didn't supplement with
copper or developing cancer because you
didn't supplement with selenium so it's
very important even though you're a
diabetic and that is your primary
immediate concern still over the Long
Haul uh being a healthc conscious person
just out of necessity
you're going to have to supplement with
all 90 essential nutrients and the odds
are even though you're a juvenile onset
type 1 diabetic you have every honest
expectation of living to be 100 symptom
free if you do everything right yes my
question is on Alzheimer's why is it
more prevalent today that than it was 15
20 years ago well actually Alzheimer's
disease was a disease that did not exist
40 years ago uh Alzheimer's disease even
by another name could not be found in
any medical dictionary or text book or
taught in any medical curriculum it only
became an entity in the medical
literature in 1979 and today it's
apparently the number four killer of
adults United States over the age of 65
behind cardiovascular disease cancer
diabetes and then comes Alzheimer's
disease and it it's appears uh to me
with no doubt that it's due to what I
call a physician caused disease because
doctors have have encouraged people in
fact demanded that people give up
saturated fat and cholesterol and move
towards a cholesterol restricted or even
a cholesterol-free diet to get their
blood cholesterol down below 200 and
they have created no less than 25 of
these cholesterol deficiency diseases
and to me Alzheimer's disease is one of
the big ones 75% of our brain weight is
pure cholesterol it's called myelin it's
this fatty stuff that insulates each
nerve fiber the brain and spinal cord
and we can only make about 10% of our
daily need of cholesterol the other 90%
must come from the diet and if a person
is very very good at giving up chicken
skin and red meat and dairy and eggs
like a doctor would have them do after
about six or eight or 10 years they're
not going to be able to keep up with the
maintenance and repair needs of the
cholesterol for the myin and the brain
and spinal cord and so you can just
expect that the person is going to
develop one or more of these 25
physician caused diseases including
acquired seizure disorders and
Alzheimer's disease now the best way to
avoid Alzheimer's disease is to eat a
couple of eggs every morning for
breakfast not cook and margin or fried
uh you want to consume as much as 72
ounces of red meat every month and I
know that sounds like a lot but it's
just a quarter pounder a day and uh you
want to supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients and when you get to the the
vitamin E level you want to have at
least 2,000 international units of
vitamin E and you want 500 micrograms of
selenium and if you do that even if you
already have Alzheimer's disease you can
expect to have a significant amount of
Return of memory great study done by the
University of California San die and the
sock Institute that says by taking 2,000
international units of vitamin E alone
even if you have advanced Alzheimer's
disease you can get a significant amount
of of memory return I've remodeled homes
for families you notice these little
children bouncing off of walls and what
they get for breakfast and a snack after
breakfast and then lunch again normally
has sugar in it is there any uh
correlation here with ADD absolutely
back at the turn of the century 1895 5
to 1900 Americans were eating a half a
pound of sugar per person per year today
it's 150 pounds of sugar per person per
year and somebody out there is eating
300 lbs because I don't eat any and I
can tell you that there's a direct
correlation between the increase in ad
ADHD depression manic depression bipolar
disease and the increased consumption of
sugar and if you look at it there's 5
million American children school age
children who are on Ridin and Prozac and
mamine and other anti-press lessons in
school 5 million drugged American kids
in in preschool and Elementary School
simply because these kids are sensitive
to Sugar like many people are sensitive
to alcohol uh there's good alcoholics
who just kind of go to sleep when they
have a couple of drinks uh there's the
people who get boisterous and sing loud
Irish songs when they take a couple of
drinks and there's some people who get
violent and and very angry and become
dangerous to themselves and other people
uh child abuse spouse abuse they abuse
their neighbors road rage is another way
of looking at this uh life-threatening
situations uh people actually will gain
criminal Behavior sometimes because
alcohol acts like a drug in them same
way with sugar some people when they
take in Sugar they have low blood sugar
and they just get drowsy and fall asleep
some people when they take in Sugar they
get hyperactive and boisterous and and
uh actually um ADD
ADHD and then there's some people when
they take in Sugar again will have road
rage uh they're very very um uh
aggressive and reactive and could be
dangerous to themselves and their
families and other people in the
community and to me it's criminal for
Coca-Cola machines and and candy
machines in school and then wonder why
kids beat up on each other or shoot Each
Other Well in addition to getting all
the sugar out of their life from sugar
Frosted Flakes and Pepsis and Reese's
Peanut Butter Cups and candy and and
Pop-Tarts and syrup on their agos uh
they have to supplement with all 90
essential nutrients even little kids
from the moment they're born to develop
properly this includes their motions and
repair and maintain themselves and
especially lithium chromium and vadium
and there's an enormous amount of
research in human beings which show that
lithium deficiency results in
hyperactivity ADD ADHD depression manic
depression and criminal behavior and so
they have to do both and you can avoid
all this uh it's amazing just within
days they will be perfectly normal
little kids my next question is my
husband and I are thinking about
starting a family and we want to know
the nut nutal way to go okay that's a
great question people always ask me when
when do children need to start taking
vitamins and minerals and the answer is
when they're still an egg is when you
want to start them and so uh we've
learned in the animal industry and
remember I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician we've learned in the animal
industry that we could prevent as much
as 98% of all birth effects even ones
that are thought to be genetic in humans
simply by giving the females especially
the females all known essential
nutrients for that species 6 months
prior to cons ception build up that
female animals body and stores of these
essential nutrients so that the embryo
implants in the uterine wall and
develops in an environment that has
optimal amounts guaranteed optimal
amounts of all the nutrients and you
will almost eliminate the possibility of
A congenital birth effect related to a
mineral or vitamin or amino acid or
essential fatty acid deficiency to give
you some idea of how successful this is
according to the University of
California San Francisco right now in
America one out of every 33 human babies
in America are born with some physical
or emotional or mental birth def one out
of 33 in animals it's only one out of
500,000 if they're fed these commercial
diets that have all the known nutrients
in them and so it's just very very easy
to understand well if we supplement
young women and men who are in the
childbearing Years with these nutrients
that we'll be able to eliminate totally
eliminate cleft pallets cleft lip
spinabifida eyee defects heart defects
hernas of various types club feet no
feet web fingers and toes no fingers and
toes uh muscular distrophy Down syndrome
cerebral py cystic fibrosis these are
all preventable with proper
preconception nutrition so the earlier
that a couple who wants to uh have
normal healthy children and have a
wonderful uncomplicated pregnancy the
earlier you can get on all 90 essential
nutrients prior to conception the better
off everybody is H Dr wallik the women
in my family are plagued with hay fever
and asthma and allergies and I don't
want to join those ranks is there a
better way absolutely uh let's start
with asthma it's the easiest one to deal
with asthma is actually a deficiency of
three nutrients magnesium manganese and
the essential fatty acids and by taking
the pig arthritis formula twice a day
you're going to get the optimal amounts
of the plant derived colloidal and the
chelated magnesium and manganese and and
then by taking the minimum daily
requirement the N gr of the essential
fatty acids and those three nutrients
together the Magnesium manganese and the
essential fatty acids will allow you to
produce what's called prostaglandins
prostaglandins are little short-lived
hormones that last in your bloodstream
30 seconds 60 seconds and your body is
continuously making them kind of Rapid
Fire and when you don't have those three
nutrients you cannot make the proper
prostaglandins to keep your bronchi and
your trachea open and that's when you
develop asthma
and it's very common when people take
all 90 essential nutrients including the
magnesium and manganese and the
essential fatty acids within weeks or
months the tightness this constant
tightness in their chest is
significantly reduced or maybe even
totally relieved the frequency and the
severity of their asthma attacks is
reduced I would certainly still keep an
inhaler available until she you know in
case you has some unexpected emergency
kind of like wearing your seat belt even
though you're on a smooth flight you
you're not going to uh anticipate sudden
turbulence you need to be prepared for
emergencies but um you have every honest
expectation of doing very well then as
far as inhalent allergies from dust and
pollin and uh seasonal ones from dust
and pollin and maybe constant ones from
danders and cats and dogs and chickens
and feathers and your pillows and that
kind of thing maybe even chemicals that
come out of rugs and verica and new cars
like f Malahide and other chemicals um
you want to get your immune system
working optimally so it can protect you
from these things because most people
are able to tolerate them and what
happens is when your immune system
doesn't have enough nutrition to
function optimally uh you become a
victim of these things assaulting you
all the time and so what you want to do
is number one take all 90 essential
nutrients so your immune system which
includes your liver and your spleen your
tonsils and your appendix your thymus uh
your um white blood cells which include
the nutrifil and the lymphocytes and the
killer tea cells and so forth also you
have eosinophils and basophils you have
neutrophils all of these white blood
cells you have albumin and globulins
which are the the immune proteins you
have antibodies themselves you have your
digestive system your skin your tears
the mucus in your body all of that
requires 90 essential nutrients to
produce this immune system which is not
just your killer tea cells uh it
includes all of these tissues and and
cells and organs of your body uh also if
you have these types of problems you
want to get some of these HEPA filters
uh at your workplace in your home when
you sleep you get the ones that you plug
in your car you want to eat as much
organically grown food as possible you
want to drink filtered Waters you want
to get as much chemicals out of your
diet as possible and reduce this
pressure on your immune system if you
have food allergies you want to have a
5day rotation diet you want to take the
enzyme which has the pepsin and the
betane hydrochloride which will help a
person digest the proteins down into
single amino acid and it's the proteins
and the allergens such as danders and
foods and pollin and dust that cause the
the allergies and even can initiate an
attack of asthma thank you you're very
welcome is it possible that you can take
too much that's a great question because
people are concerned about overdosing
with vitamins and minerals the general
answer is that if you look at the
medical profession according to the
Center for Disease Control Harvard IAL
School the US News and World Report
Ralph nater Sydney wolf Rand Corporation
and many many other well-respected
institutions they say that doctors kill
150,000 to 300,000 Americans each year
in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence doctors injure 1.3
million Americans each year in hospitals
alone as a result of medical negligence
and doctors infect 2 million Americans
alone in hospitals as a result of
medical negligence for a total of 3 and
A5 million casualties inflicted on the
American public each year in hospitals
just as as a result of medical
negligence on the other side of this
picture there's not a single person
who's overdosed in vitamins and minerals
and trace minerals to the point where
they have to be hospitalized or anything
bad happen and so when you compare the
safety of vitamins and minerals and
Trace minals compared with standard
medical procedures it's enormously safe
and that's why I'm so excited about
nutrition and the pig arthritis formula
and the plant derived chal minerals and
that's the direction I'd go Dr wallik my
16-year-old daughter has been diagnosed
with fibromyalgia what can you do for
her well it's actually an easy one we
eliminated fibromyalgia in animals in
1957 and in sheep it was called stiff
lamb disease and also in sheep and
calves and fos with baby horses and
chickens and turkeys and any any other
animal that was raised for meat uh the
disease is uh caused by a deficiency of
three nutrients the trace mineral
selenium vitamin E and the sulfur
bearing amino acid methionine and
there's two things you have to do to
deal with fibromy number one eliminate
the free radicals and the trans fatty
acids that actually initiate damage to
the muscle and cause a scarring of the
muscle tissue which is very painful even
normal muscle movement and you can
understand why they call it stiff lamb
disease if you have
fibromyalgia first of all you eliminate
fried foods such as fried potatoes which
are you know the teenagers live on fried
potatoes right so you have to eliminate
fried potatoes Fried Chicken fish shrimp
fried eggs uh tempura stir fry anything
fried all margarine salad dressings with
oils in them have to be eliminated and
then again the pig arthritis form is
perfect because it has optimal amounts
of the trace mineral selenium and both
the plant derived colloidal and the
chelated form it has optimal amounts of
vitamin E and the sulfur bearing amino
acid methionine and it just works like a
charm very quickly within weeks or
months they feel and they can recognize
some benefit and many people will get
significant benefit very quickly Dr Ric
are baby formulas enough for our babies
when they're born unfortunately not uh
our our formulas that we give to dogs
whether it's kind of like um science.
dog food or the puppy or kitten milk
replacers for puppies and kittens you're
going to raise by hand have 40 minerals
in them including the uh minerals um
lithium chromium vadium and selenium Ral
pinao laboratory rat pellets contain 28
minerals including lithium chromium
vadium and selenium there's not a single
human milk replacer on the market on a
off the shelf of a grocery store that
has more than 12 minerals none of them
contain lithium chromium vadium and only
two pro soybean infam have selenium in
them and uh it's tragic that we give our
dogs 40 minerals and our rats 28 and our
kids 12 or less you can begin to see why
we spent $1.2 trillion for Health Care
last year you begin to see why we only
live to be
75.5 half of our genetic potential for a
longevity of 120 to 140 why we only rank
17th in longevity and 19th in
healthfulness simply because we don't
get the basic raw material to develop
properly and maintain repair cells from
the very beginning I'll give you a
tragic example sudden infant death
syndrome is something that everybody is
familiar with we eliminated sudden
infant death syndrome in animals back in
the 1950s because Farmers can't afford
to lose two or three or five or 10% of
the baby animals are raising to sudden
infant death syndrome and we learned
that it was due to a deficiency of the
Trac Min slam causing sudden death in
the most robust the healthiest of the
baby animals in in the group or the herd
or the fly
and we eliminate it simply by giving the
pregnant mothers selenium and as soon as
the baby is born or hatch they get
selenium and if you look at the human
infant milk replacers on the market only
two of all of them put selenium in the
formula and so if I was going to raise a
child today on these infant milk
replacers these infant milk formulas in
a can or a bottle or a box I would pick
the two pro soybean infam that have
selenium in them and to stack things in
favor of the child I would still give
them from the moment they're born a
teaspoon for 20 lbs of body weight of
the pig arthritis formula twice a day
obviously you may not want to use the
orange juice in a newborn baby because
it can develop allergies to it but I
would still give them the plant derived
Cal and the chelated minerals and
vitamins and amino acids and the tragic
example of this is 65% this is a known
fact 65% of all the babies dying of
sudden infant DND Drome in America are
being fed canned milk replacers two3
are the ones who die of sudden infant
death syndrome are being fed these
canned infant formulas and I guarantee
you they're being fed the ones that
don't have selenium in them and so uh
absolutely it's important to supplement
these babies from birth because you
can't get everything you need from your
for food group certainly not out of
these canned formulas great thank
you